all right so one question i get asked
all the time is lucy i have an aws
interview coming up what type of
questions do they ask and how should i
prepare now you've done the hard part of
getting your resume noticed by the
recruiter but how do you then ace the
interviews and land the job if you're
new to this channel welcome i'm an
associate solutions architect working at
amazon web services and i make videos to
help people build their technical skills
and land a job in the cloud computing
industry so in this video i want to
share with you the most frequently asked
questions in the solutions architect
interview and provide tips on how to
answer them whether you have an upcoming
interview or at the very start of your
cloud learning journey i would highly
recommend watching this video to the end
to understand what exactly you need to
know to become a solutions architect
just as a disclaimer the questions i'm
about to share are all publicly
available on interview preparation
websites and aren't sourced internally
from aws a big thank you to today's
sponsor squarespace but more about them
later in the video okay let's dive
straight into it so the solutions
architect interview at aws typically
consists of these three rounds first of
all you have your online screening
followed by your phone interview and
four on-site interviews the four on-site
interviews have a mix of technical and
non-technical questions the technical
questions have general ones and
questions more related to the essay role
you may also be asked to do a technical
presentation where you walk through a
technical solution on a problem you've
solved in the past because our main
focus today is on the technical
component i will walk you through step
by step how to answer five common
questions after that i'll provide five
bonus questions for you to prepare on
your own question number one what is
your current understanding of the
solutions arctic role and why are you
interested in it now this question is
usually one of the first questions they
like to ask in the solutions arctic
interview the best way to answer this
question is to define the solutions
arctic role in your own words and
explain how your skills and interests
align to the position for example i
would mention that a solutions architect
is a trusted technical advisor for
customers as they go along the journey
with using the cloud it's a role that
requires both customer facing skills and
technical skills in order to help
customers come up with scalable flexible
and resilient architectures this role
aligns with my interest because i like
to dive deep into technical problems and
have a passion for helping others i
could also talk about my previous
experiences working in customer facing
roles and mention any aws certifications
i've gotten question number two can you
explain the benefits of cloud computing
this question is quite interesting
because different cloud computing
providers have their own way of defining
the benefits in aws we define cloud
computing as the on-demand delivery of
iot resources over the internet with a
pay-as-you-go model and here are the
four benefits we emphasize to customers
agility elasticity cost savings and the
ability to deploy globally in minutes
i'll leave a link down below that
describes the benefits in more detail
click pause this video is brought to you
by squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the online platform for
you to run your business and build a
beautiful online presence if you're
looking to create your own website get
started with the best-in-class website
template and customize it to fit your
needs you can browse through different
categories and find the perfect starting
place you can also sell your products on
an online store whether you sell
physical or digital products squarespace
has the tools you need to start selling
online every squarespace website and
online store comes with a suite of
integrated features and useful guides to
help maximize prominence among search
results head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com tech with
lucy to save 10 of your first purchase
of a website or domain now let's get
back to the video so question number
three is what's the difference between a
sql database and a nosql database this
question is quite straightforward a sql
database holds structured data and a
nosql database holds unstructured data
sql databases are better for multi-row
transactions while no sql databases are
better for unstructured data like
documents or json files you may also be
asked to provide an example of a sql
database or nosql database so here are
some examples of each question number
four how do you secure a three-tier web
application in the cloud the first step
is to make sure you understand what a 3t
web application is it's made up of a
presentation tier an application tier
and a data tier in this answer make sure
you cover these points so for networking
best practices make sure you configure
subnets for each tier make use of
network access control lists and
properly define your route tables you
also want to mention data protection so
ensuring databases and storage are
encrypted and finally identity and
access management so making sure each
application component has the proper
level of access required to communicate
with other components question number
five give me an example of how you might
use machine learning to enhance a
product or bring benefit to a company
okay so there are many many benefits and
use cases for machine learning but
here's an example let's say you run an
e-commerce website for example
amazon.com once a customer buys
something they get recommended with
other products to buy based on the
purchase history of similar shoppers and
this is done with the help of machine
learning i recommend doing some research
to understand how it works behind the
scenes and as promised here are five
bonus questions for you to prepare for
how do you scale your application for a
big traffic day what happens behind the
scenes when you hit enter on a website
url for example google.com what is the
difference between infrastructure as a
service platform as a service and
software as a service what are
containers and how do you migrate an
application from on-premises to the
cloud so those are some examples of the
types of technical questions you might
expect from a solutions arctic interview
feel free to leave your answers in the
comments below to help each other out my
biggest piece of advice is to make sure
you're open and honest with what you
know and what you don't know so yeah
just be yourself take a deep breath make
sure you're prepared before the
interview but on the day if there's
anything you're not sure about let the
interviewer know all right so this
brings us to the end of this video thank
you so much for watching please give
this video a like if you got something
out of it let me know in the comments
what type of videos you would like to
see next alright bye for now